school is where children should feel
safe to learn but it's also where many
young people are sexually harassed for
the first time
for some it's a shameful experience they
hide
but now a website detailing their
accounts is revealing the scale of the
problem
it was set up by 22 year old sama sara
after talking to her friends about their
shared experience
during those school years those teenage
years
you know behaviors within rape culture
so this could be you know cat calling
public sexual harassment
stealthing image-based abuse which is an
umbrella term for
um tech abuse like revenge porn or
sexting coercion all of these behaviours
were completely normalized
and casually perpetrated by people i
knew growing up
testimonies on her website paint a toxic
picture of misogyny
among teenagers one girl wrote boys used
to run their hands
up and down our thighs in lessons up
under our skirts
and after she was sexually assaulted a
young girl wrote i still get banter
about it and wake up screaming
sommer says that part of the problem is
the toxic influence of online porn
it creates that idea that boys have an
entitlement to female bodies
and consent is practically non-existent
in
much of pornography and a lot of the
time when i was growing up
my sex education wasn't serious so for a
lot of these people
porn was a sex education social media
has doubled the effect of the abuse
experts say
because it's made young girls accessible
wherever they are
and schools have not caught up in their
efforts to tackle issues of consent
in the digital sphere we're not teaching
young men that if they
send a nude picture of their girlfriend
around the school that that is
unconsensual
we're not really talking about cyber
flashing
or the unsolicited sharing and sending
of of genitals to young women's inboxes
which is a huge issue
and the problem with this is that it
normalizes
these types of behaviors you might think
that these types of behaviors are
relatively small
but it acts as a gateway for other forms
of sexual violence
in the wake of the murder of sarah
everard conversations about women's
safety have been brought into the
spotlight
changing attitudes campaigners say needs
to start
at a much younger age milena
vaselinovich sky news